it's such a privilege to be part of this
inaugural js conf mexico so i'd like to
thank the organizers for having me
now today i'll be speaking on a topic
that i know may not be everybody's cup
of tea and that's fine i don't expect
everyone to fall in love with css after
this
but i do hope that you'll find some of
the things i'll be sharing useful
and hopefully it will also aid in your
understanding of how modern
css layouts work so let's get right into
it
the first thing i want to cover today is
something called content
based sizing so the concept of
automatic sizing has always existed
since the earliest days of the browser
because browsers have always managed to
figure out how much space content should
take up without any intervention
from us like the content would reflow
without overlapping you didn't have to
write anything
special for it just part of the web
what we have in a relatively recent css
specification known as the css intrinsic
and extrinsic
sizing module level 3 is
the height and with css properties now
can take three additional keyword values
which are min content max content and
fit content so the keyword here is
content
so this these widths
these uh keyword values actually give
authors the option
of assigning automatic widths to the
elements
on that on the page so let's go through
what
this means right so the first thing
we're going to cover
is min content min content
is the smallest size a box could take
that doesn't lead to overflow
so if there's any inline content
it instead of overflowing it will break
into multiple
lines now line breaking might be
something most of us don't give a second
thought to
but there is a lot of nuance depending
on the language
being used for many languages like say
english or mexican line breaks tend to
occur at
word boundaries where spaces or
punctuation
are used to explicitly separate words
and browsers will not break words by
default
so in this first example here the word
content
plus the full stop at the end is treated
as a single
unbreakable entity and that ends up
being the width
of this first box in other languages
though specifically for the east asian
languages
like chinese or japanese that utilize
han characters the break is per
character most of the time but not
always
because there are rules about certain
characters that are not allowed to start
or end a line now east asian scripts
also use
this thing called full width punctuation
so what this means is that
if i add a full width say comma
right here
this box is now two characters wide
instead of one because in east asian
languages
the punctuation takes up the full width
of a character
now we also have some other southeast
asian scripts for example like
thai which are written without any
spaces
between the words so the text can be
wrapped at
syllable boundaries in addition to word
boundaries
so before i talk about the buy box let's
go
into the second keyword value which is
max content and it'll make things easier
to explain
max content is kind of like the opposite
of mint content where
it is the boxes ideal size in a given
axis
if there's like infinite space like if
there's lots of space
that's the size of the box that can fit
the content
perfectly so content just takes up as
much space as required to lay itself out
on one
single line so for the thigh example
if you don't read thai like i don't read
thai i wouldn't know where the word
breaks
what happened but the
word that is longest here is this word
called prayok
and that is where the word broke in the
min content box
and that's why that's the size of the
mint content box
but in a max content situation everyone
is a single line that's the amount of
space that's gonna take up
and that's how max content looks like
now there's a third value
fit content unfortunately this is not a
supported value
right now but all of these three
keywords i just mentioned are supported
when used in the context
of a grid formatting layout so let's
look at this grid
here i'll highlight it you can see i'm
using display grid to do it
so fit content it's not like a fixed
value
compared to main content or max content
it is actually a range right it is a
range between the min
content size and the max content size of
a run of text
um it could also be a length percentage
because if you look at the syntax
it's actually like a function so you can
actually add a value
inside the parentheses this is pretty
hard to explain in words so i'm
hoping that the dev tools can help me in
this explanation so this
particular example here we can see three
columns that are sized with min content
max content and fit content respectively
so now if we look at this max content
run of text
it is about
480 pixels
now when i resize the browser the fit
content box
will shrink to a minimum
size that is equal to min
content but if there's a lot of space
i'm gonna expand the browser
it's gonna keep growing until it hits
300 pixels which is the value
that i've put inside the parentheses
if you look at the code i put a value of
fit content 300 pixels for that last
column
and that's why it stops growing at 300.
now say
if i change this 300 value to something
greater
than 482 because in in case you don't
read 100 characters
all three columns have exactly the same
run of text
you change this to 500 so 500
is longer than the max content
of the text but if i keep expanding
the browser you'll notice that it
doesn't hit
the value of 500 that i put in the
parentheses it will
stop and the max content width so that's
how fit content
works it is the
range between the min content size and
either the max content size or the
length percentage defined
within the parentheses
so now that we've got these basics
covered i think we're ready
to move on to the next section which is
about
flexbox now flexbox was the first layout
model that was designed specifically
for building web layouts and it is a lot
more powerful than the previous
techniques
that we've had flexbox allows the
browser to take over sizing based
on the amount of available space
so this can be quite confusing at first
because the
end result may not be what you
explicitly
said for now firefox is the only browser
with a flexbox
inspector so let's take a look at this
right
so i'm using firefox right now if you go
over to the layout tab
you will see that there is a flexbox
option
and so i'm just going to highlight my
first example here
in the inspector you can either choose
to activate this tab
or you could have chosen to toggle it
either way is fine but when the overlay
is toggled
what you can see is the outlines of each
flex item
and also the amount of free space
available as
sort of this dotted line texture thing
if you look
at the layout panel it will tell you the
flex direction
its wrap status and more importantly
it tells you what the browser does when
it grows or shrinks
your flex item and i will talk about
this a bit more
in the examples below
what i find really cool about flexbox is
the amount of control it gives us over
this distribution
of free space it's kind of a newer way
of thinking about how we lay out our
items
on a page now the sizing of flex items
does
depend on a number of factors so it
depends on the amount of free space
available
the amount of content within the flex
item even the starting width
of the flex item now the exact algorithm
is
sort of complicated but it is outlined
in detail
in the specification if you're
interested in the how the calculations
actually work
and personally i feel that the key to
figuring out
flexbox is understanding how the flex
basis
property works say i put
a fixed value of 100 pixels as the flex
basis of a flex item
i feel that intuitively many people
expect to see
a box with a width of 100 pixels because
we're so
used to being in control of our sizing
instructions
but flex basis is actually the starting
point
from which the size of the box is
calculated
so remember that the key here is the
starting point
because if your flex items are allowed
to grow or shrink
odds are the final size may not
be whatever you put in the flex basis
so let's move on to this next section
flex box basics because i want to talk
about this scenario i want to talk about
the scenario
where the same flex values could
potentially
give you different end results so if we
look at the content
of my two examples here three columns
first two columns have
exactly the same content right this is a
sentence
word both have it the only difference
between these two sets
of content and let's highlight it to see
so both of these divs
have the same styles on it so if you
look
here you'll see that both of these divs
they are
set to display flex that is all nothing
layout specific um
each of the flex items themselves are
not styled explicitly
so this means that the flex items are
taking the initial
values so
if you look here flexbox actually has a
number of
keyword values that resolved these um
because flex itself is a shorthand right
so in result it revolve
resolves sorry to these values
the initial value of flex if you don't
do anything the default value that the
browser applies is that a flex grow of 0
a flex string of one and a flex basis
of auto and this is what we have in our
first two examples i'm going to come
back here so you can see
so i mean it's totally possible to
change the flex
values but by default if you don't do
anything it's zero
when auto so what this means is that
flex items won't grow beyond their
starting widths
so if i resize resize resize resize
you'll notice that it doesn't grow
beyond the max content
but a flex string value of 1 means that
all the items will start to shrink
at the same rate if there isn't enough
space for all the content
to be on a single line so if i start to
shrink
at about this point the
second example the second set of content
has to start shrinking at this point
because there isn't any more free space
so everybody who can shrink has to start
drinking
so when i presented this example i think
it was somewhere here
the second column had already shrunk
quite significantly whereas for the
first set of examples
plenty of free space no shrinkage
required
so even though the same flex values
are applying on both of these examples
you'll notice that the size
of the second box completely different
right so let's talk about flex basis in
this case right
the initial value of flex basis is auto
and auto typically resolves to the max
content width now when there is no
explicit width set on a flex item
which means that the width of the flex
item as well as flex basis is resolved
to auto
the browser tends to use the content
size as
its starting point so let's see what the
flexbox inspector can show
us i'm gonna highlight this so you can
see
so the initial size which is the content
size
is about one two
one zero two four pixels right and
because there wasn't enough space
the browser shrunk it given that the
flex string value
was one and this is the final size that
we're actually seeing
on the page i thought this was a pretty
useful visualization
now if we happen to have an explicit
width
on this box so i'm going to do this now
let's do
a width of say 200 pixels
this width becomes the starting point
for the calculation
now in this specific example because our
flex growth factor is zero
there's no growing involved and the
final size ends up being 200 it's 198
because
of the borders right
but what's interesting is that if there
is
a flex basis value so let's let's keep
the two
the growing strings the same let's give
it a flex basis of 300
you'll notice that even though there is
an explicit width set on this box
because of the flag spaces the
starting size for calculation becomes
300 instead
so knowing this sometimes when you set a
width and you realize that wait that's
not the width i said
maybe it's it's this maybe it's a flex
item with an
explicit flex basis set just something
to take note of
so let's move on to this bit called free
space distribution because i want to
explain the difference between having a
flex basis
of auto and a flex basis of zero
so again i have two sets of three items
but this time
exactly the same content for both
they have different flex values though
so let's go
and see what's what so for this first
example
i have a flex value of auto
on the box so auto resolves to
grow of one shrink of one basis
of auto for the second one
everything's the same except i made it
grow
by two instead of one for the final box
it's just zero growth
so the other two the the two values of
flex shrink and flex basis is the same
for everyone so in this
situation let me expand
this you'll notice that there is
free space and this free space is being
distributed in the ratio
of two is to one so i'm just gonna
highlight this here
so if you look at the diagram it shows
you the original size
which is about let's call it 254
and because there was extra space this
item was set to grow
and the amount of space it was allocated
is about 77 pixels
now if we look at the one with a flex
grow value of two
what you'll see is that it has
double the amount of free space as
compared
to the first one so that's the
implication of using a flex grow value
uh of of double or whatever ratio you
have between
your flex items so if you look at the
final size
they're definitely not multiples
of each other like this second box is
not twice the size
of the first if you didn't want that
sort of a scenario
that's when the flex bases being set to
zero
comes in so by setting a flex basis of
zero what you're telling the browser is
that there is
no starting with for each item which
means it doesn't take into account the
content size
anymore so if you look at this box with
this flex basis set to zero
all of the space is all of the free
space
is up for grabs so
this as we've established earlier
in the content sizing page browser is
not going to break
words right so it's going to shrink
this column to its max to its min
content size and then that's it there's
like there's no free space here
so whatever's free space that's getting
distributed
is the amount of space across
this viewport
and all of this space is being allocated
to these two columns and the ratio of
one is to two
so that's why this first box is 324
and the second box is twice of that
value
so this is the difference this is the
difference
in sizing you can achieve with flexbox
just by changing the flex basis
value so depending on the end result
you want this is something to take note
of that you have options
and it will affect the size of your flex
items
one more thing i want to talk about for
flexbox
is the fact that you can use box
alignment
properties on it so the ability to
align items with the box alignment
properties is also a very big plus
so this flex inspector also allows us to
visualize the free space
that is distributed for all the
different values so let's
let's highlight this again if you look
at
the flex overlay like i said outlines of
sex items
what are we interested here for box
alignment is all this free space
so box alignment properties were meant
to be used across
different layout models even though for
now they can only be used
with flex and grid what i really like
about devtools and uh even though i'm
using firefox now i'm pretty sure
chrome does this it is the magic of auto
complete so you know you can kind of if
even if you can't remember what each of
these properties do you can kind of just
run through the keywords until you get
the one you want but anyway what i'm
trying to say
is that there are numerous options that
allow you to distribute the free space
not only the entire
block of your content you can even
distribute space between your items
three sets of values for that all
prefixed with space
so we do have a lot of flexibility when
it comes to
distributing our flex items within its
own
container so justify content lets us
adjust flex items along the main axis
which is this direction
that flex items are laid out so
it moves like i showed in the example it
moves all the flex children within the
container
or disperses the extra space between
them
if we change the flex direction
to column
[Music]
cut spell direction
and then we should give the container a
height
um let's just give an arbitrary value 45
so you can see that we can also change
the direction
that the content is flowing so
the main axis is now flowing from top to
bottom and the flex items
move in this direction i hope you all
can see my cursor
instead so what i mentioned was the main
axis
what is perpendicular to it is called
the cross
axis which is whatever is perpendicular
to the main axis
so if you look at my items they all like
suspiciously are the same height
this is because items are stretched
along the cross axis to the full height
of the flex line the moment you put on
the display flex
but if we do any self alignment
properties let's
try align items
they immediately shrink to their
original heights so this behavior will
also happen
for grid items one interesting
value for align items is called
baseline and this is useful when you
have something like my example here
where you have like different font sizes
different line heights
you can actually use baseline to sort of
align
all the textual content across your flex
items so if you happen to have some sort
of a
i don't know editorial design that
involves these
different flex items of different
heights you could kind of align
everyone's baseline together just to
make it easier to read have
a container flex container that is a lot
longer
than the total height
of your flex lines for example let me
change this to something big
let's try something like this so you'll
notice that there's a lot of these
white spaces between your flex items
so there is an option for you to pack
your flex lines together using align
content
so for example if i set it to start it
kind of packs away
everyone to the top leaving the extras
free space
at the bottom so these are the box
alignment properties
that you have that you can use to align
your items within
your container now moving on
can't talk about css layout without grid
so regardless of whether you've used
grid in production or you're just trying
it out for the first time
it's really helpful to have a grid
inspector tool
so the most basic usage of laying out
items with grid is
setting the track sizes of your
rows and columns so the browser will
automatically place items into the grid
using a very well bought out algorithm
that is defined in a specification if
anyone is interested
but things being placed one after
another
it's pretty pretty standard behavior you
know you don't need grid
to put things in order but let's talk
about this grid highlighter
why not so similarly it's also it also
exists
in the layout panel and you have options
you can display line numbers
you can display area names we'll talk
about that later you can extend
lines indefinitely which is great if you
have multiple
grids on the same page so that's fun
so this basic example i
really like the syntax of grid right so
if you look at it
we have display grid and then we set
columns and rows
if there are three volume sorry three
values
in grid template columns you see three
columns
there are two rows and i see two rows
so as a visual person i appreciate this
type of syntax
like i said nothing special about things
laid out one after another
what's special about grid is how simple
it is to manually place items
in both directions so since my favorite
analogy for this is placing items on a
chessboard
this example it is what it is this is a
simple three by three grid
i'm gonna find it highlight it so we can
see
nothing spectacular one container three
items
the properties which control the
grid items which contain chess pieces
are grid roll
and grid column so this is where the
ability to see
line numbers comes in really handy
so if you look at the second one i
wanted it smack in the middle of the
board
so i set the grid row to two as you can
see
here two grid row two
gives it sets it here column two sets it
here that's how it gets to the middle if
you look at the last one
with row three grid column three so
that's what that's how we place
items in the grid so numbers when it
comes to
more complex layouts let's say i don't
know if you have 20 columns you're not
going to sit there and count columns
take a look at the grid number boom
there you have it
that's why i think this grid overlay is
super useful
now i mentioned this area names thing
so this is another feature of grid that
i really like um so if you look at the
syntax it looks a bit
like why is it so complicated it's
actually not it's just that the
devtools does smoosh the values together
a bit
but what we can do after we've allocated
columns and rows is that we can assign
certain areas
with every names so how the syntax works
is that
there are a bunch of lines that i have
here that are surrounded by codes
so each of these set each of the
codes represent a row and each of the
values within the codes
represents the column so because i have
a six by six here i must have
six rows and six column values
otherwise the grid template this whole
piece of code is moot do with grid
template areas is that we can modify
the size of our grid items without
actually changing the grid item code
itself
so as you can see after assigning grid
template areas
i can assign each item to its respective
areas so this one i say grade area
grade area mouse grid area of the lingo
but if i want to change the size of
the cell not the cell sorry the area
i can do it directly from
the grid template areas code like so
i hope i don't type anything wrong
otherwise my code is going
moot let's try this
there you go so instead of four cells
mouse noun takes up two cells
didn't have to change anything down here
only had to change it
on the grid container level so i thought
that was
pretty useful especially when we're
doing things like
full page layouts where you do have to
adjust the size
of your elements depending on the
viewport
you don't really have to go and find
every single
grid item and then code for its position
depending on the viewport you can
isolate all your so-called responsive
code only to the grid container
i think that's pretty useful
this last bit here animating grid rows
and columns
when i started talking about this it was
still early it was it came out in
firefox 66 i think we're at 84 now
so this feature has been around for a
bit not sure when the other
browsers are going to implement it but
you can
animate grid columns and rows this
had always been written into the
specification it just took some time for
the browsers to ship
this feature now without dev tools
honestly
it might seem as if this chess piece is
jumping the grid rows and columns
that's fake news my friends can't
actually do that
so this is a trick there's actually only
one grid item and
there is only two rows
and two columns
right so if i scroll down to
the keyframes this is what's going on
you can actually animate the column
size or row size and that's
exactly what's happening here and i use
the box alignment properties to assign
the chest piece to the bottom right
corner
of the first cell
and that's what's changing the
background is big it is
a linear gradient
what is fun since i first started giving
this talk is that
chrome has recently joined
the grid inspector to party
so if you are using chrome
inspect i have good news for all of you
i'm on canary so this is taking a while
there is also
a grid inspector in chrome now
so the advantage of this is it's
almost feature parity with firefox in
terms of usage so you go to the layout
panel
and you can see they also allow you to
show area names
line numbers they have this thing called
track sizes that's printed directly
um to be fair this is a new feature
for chrome so clearly there are some
bugs
and rendering issues that need to be
worked out but the fact that they've
shipped this this means they're gonna
have to keep improving it
so if you really love using chrome
well good news grid inspector shipped
hopefully
they'll start shipping the other layout
tools as well so everybody
will have a good time doing css moving
on
i want to talk about this concept called
flexible sizing uh
it's a pretty big thing when it comes to
grid and it's actually a fairly
interesting
new aspect of building modern css
layouts
because when we used to talk about
length css lengths we use relative units
like percentages or even the newer
viewport units
that's all fine and good for responsive
design yes but the problem is that they
make all of your elements
change size at the same rate
so when we use css grid css grid
actually does
introduce a lot of new features one of
the things is
this new unit called the fr unit
which is the amount of free space
available
it also introduces this min max function
as well as there are other intrinsic
sizing values like fit content that we
covered
we also have auto which has been around
for a while
and all of these different values they
don't change at the same rate so i'm
going to explain this
with these visual examples on the screen
so all the sizing units that i just
talked about
are supported in grid so all of these
examples
naturally are grid so there's gonna be a
lot of browser resizing coming up
i mean the alternative talk title for
this presentation is
what do you mean you don't size your
browser a thousand times a day right
so it's gonna have a lot of examples um
let's look at this first set of four
which covers fr
and auto so if our screen auto is blue
for fr i have set the value
1fr 2fr and 1fr you know just to
make a distinction that with fr you can
actually explicitly state how much
free space is being distributed so
first and third are half of the second
box
that's because we set it that way auto
behaves
rather similarly to fr if it's used in
isolation
so everything if i have three boxes i
set them all to auto they all have the
same width
cool now when they're used together
you'll see
that fr will
take up any extra space available
so if there's lots of space in the
viewport all this extra space
goes straight to the green box which is
sized with fr
but when there is no space so when i
start shrinking the browser
it's also the first to get space taken
away
and as i take away more space
you'll notice that the blue boxes don't
change they are
always fixed at max content when all
this like space stuff is happening with
the green box
so it's going to keep continue shrinking
until the fr box hits min
content so the moment it hits mean
content that means
green box has strung as much as it could
and then space starts getting taken away
from the blue boxes
ultimately when there is absolutely no
space left behind all three boxes are
going to end up
exactly the same size but they did they
did not change
their size at the same rate i'm going to
cover
fit content versus min max i think this
is a fairly
interesting comparison to make so
fit content and min max they do behave
quite similarly in that there are both a
range of values with a minimum
and maximum value so min max takes two
arguments the first one being the
minimum size and the second one
being the maximum we've already talked
about how fit content works earlier so
let's look at example five
we have in fr box and autumn box in a
fit content
box if we
start losing space so like i don't this
is maximum space so green
clearly has lots of room to work with
it's also the first shrink so we're
gonna keep shrinking it
you'll notice that fit content
and auto end up reaching their minimum
sizes at the same time even though their
behavior
is slightly different
the comparison is more apparent when we
look at example six
so now we still have a blue box that is
sized auto but we have this
min max yellow box gold box whatever
right here so this
things are starting to get a bit
interesting because when
the column grows or shrinks is different
so again i'm just going to start off
with something that a lot of space
auto gets all the space when there's
plenty of it
and gives up that space when
the browser's the viewport starts to
shrink
once auto hits its max content
size here
it's going to stop shrinking it's going
to keep its max content size
the next box to start shrinking is
actually the gold box
the min max box so you'll see min max
starts to shrink
and as we keep going there is one point
where everybody starts to shrink
together
exactly where i can't say but this is
the point that allows all three of them
to end up
hitting their minimum size at the
same time
here okay here ish
so these two will end up being mint
content
while min max will stop at 200 so all of
them
hit their respective minimum sizes
at the same time so
when there's a lot of space the fit
content gets kept at its
max content with uh in this example i
set it to 200
while auto and min max continue
to grow so this is about the point where
it hits
almost 200
and then when auto reaches its max
content size
it stops growing and then the min max
box starts to grow
hits 400 then stops and then blue starts
to grow again
so what i'm trying to demonstrate in
these
examples is the fact that we can
actually have
our elements kind of wait for each other
so you might be thinking sure current
boxes are cool how do i use this in real
life
really glad you asked so i have two
examples here
it's kind of a i feel this is a design
that is not in common you see
this on feature com feature articles
feature stories you have a
big nice image you have a
title stylized so both of these look
very similar
at a full viewport
with things start to
become apparent that their size
differently once the viewport starts to
get smaller
so the first example i've used
percentages
to size the elements and add a small
width
i'm just going to shrink this you'll
start to notice
that because everything is shrinking at
the same rate
because these are percentages the image
is becoming too small
the text is kind of like not
set nicely it's a bit too squished up
that's because everyone is shrinking at
the same rate so
in order to tackle this you probably
have to add a view
a break point somewhere and rejig the
percentages so you can see what i've
been saying i said it a 65
and some other percentages this is
awkward margin top thing here too
but the second example doesn't suffer
from this this problem
because i've used all these flexible
variable sizing units that we talked
about in the colored boxes
example that allows us to have a more
robust
layout so even at a tiny
viewport with i don't have to write any
extra
break points just to deal with this
situation
so i think that's a pretty interesting
implementation
of this flexible sizing that i talked
about
now even though css
properties seem pretty powerful on their
own i think we've demonstrated through
display grid
flex etc there are a lot
of css properties i think they have over
500 the last i checked
and css kind of makes magic
when all these individual properties are
combined
in creative ways because grid allows us
to do things like
overlap much easier than before so
if we combine so it's not in just layout
right if we can combine a layout
css like grid with things like say blend
modes or masks
or background clip css shapes etc
we can do some really interesting things
uh this
is may this is just this very you know
rudimentary example
using mixed blend modes and the variable
sizing
for my columns but i can only imagine
that those of you
with a creative streak can come up with
so much
better than what i've done so far but
there's so many
possibilities for much more creative
expression
on the web right now so to wrap up i
just want to say
that you know css is evolving it's
becoming more powerful
a lot of the older layout hacks are no
longer
necessary because we have these new
layout properties that are designed
specifically
to suit the dynamic nature of the web
and with them come new concepts to be
learned
so hopefully what i've covered hopefully
you start
using some of these dev tool features to
help
in your understanding and i guess i just
want to round up by saying that if
you've been on the fence
about these trying out these new
features i just want to say
you know just do it it's not
as scary as you think thank you very
much